for the there's backstage they said for
the fashion minded ladies in the
audience would I just say a few words
now and then about some of the lovely
gowns worn by our glamorous presenters
and I'm very not an authority I'll do my
best anyway here to announce the winner
of best song wearing a Grecian sheets of
white crepe with a sculptor color of
iridescent two furrows the provocative
accessories including a swirling scarf
of timid pink and matching shoes Miss
Mary Jones
it sounds like a wonderful dress Jack I
wish I had one like it
the nominees for the best song award are
James Van Heusen and Sammy Kahn for call
me irresponsible Henry Mancini and
Johnny Mercer for sure a Max David and
Ernest gold for it's a mad mad mad mad
world riz ortolani nino Oliviero and
norman newell for more dmitri Tompkins
and Paul Francis Webster for so little
time the winners are James Van Heusen
and Sammy Cahn
for my father mr. Khan I thank you I'd
like to express my thanks along with the
thanks of my father I'm deeply grateful
to the members of the Academy thank you
very much